في تطورات المعارك ايضا نتعرف اكثر على ما
يدور في الجبهات ففي جبهه بخموت قالت
سلطات دنيتك المواليه لروسيا ان نحو عشره
الاف جندي اوكراني ما زالوا محاصرين في
بخموت بينما قال مؤسس شركه فاجنر العسكريه
ان قواته تشدد قبضتها على مدينه باخموت
لكنه اضاف ان حرمان قواته من الذخيره
سيؤثر على الجبهه بكاملها في جبهات اخرى
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان قواتها
تصدت لهجمات روسيه على محاور بخموت ولمان
وشختار في مقاطعه دنيتك وكوبيانسك في
مقاطعه خير وقالت ان موسكو نفذت عشرات
الغارات والقصف بالصواريخ على هذه المحاور
تنضم الينا بل ينضم الينا من كوستنوني
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود ومن موسكو
مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي ابدا بك حسان
وتطورات في باخموت
والجبهه الشرقيه من الناحيه الاوكرانيه
نعم عثمان يبدو ان هذه المعارك والقصف
المتبادل بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه
في تصاعد عند جبهه باخموت نحن الان عند
المنطقه الغربيه
لباخمت ونسمع اصوات القصف وكذلك نرى اثار
الدخان المتصاعد من المنطقه التي تتعرض
للقصف وكذلك يتم القصف منها باتجاه مواقع
القوات الروسيه في منطقه جنوب غرب بخموت
وكذلك باتجاه المواقع التي تمكنت القوات
الروسيه من الوصول اليها في محيط منطقه
باخموت من هذه المناطق طيله الوقت نتابع
القصف والقصف المضاد تسقط الصواريخ
والقذائف المدفعيه هنا في هذه المنطقه
وكذلك تنطلق الصواريخ من المنطقه الغربيه
باتجاه مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه هذا
ايضا يضاف الى رصدنا لطائرات روسيه فوق
سماء منطقه جورليفكا هذه المنطقه التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه منذ عام 2014
وهذه المنطقه
رصدنا في سمائها طائرات
روسيه تابعه لسلاح الجو الروسي قامت
بتنفيذ غارات على منطقه نيويورك في جنوبي
منطقه باخموت هذه البلده هي قريبه من
منطقه جورليفكا وعند وجودنا هناك ايضا
سمعنا
اصوات القصف بالصواريخ من الطائرات على
تلك المنطقه هذا هو الواقع على الجبهه
جبهه بخمه التي تشهد قصفا وقصفا متبادلا
من جهه فيما تستمر المعارك ايضا في
الاحياء وضواحي هذه المدينه كما تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه اخر المعطيات ايضا ما
اشار له المتحدث باسم الاداره العسكريه
وقياده عمليات الشرق الاوكراني الذي اكد
ان القوات الاوكرانيه في منطقه بخبط ما
زالت تواصل المعركه وان الوضع هناك رغم
صعوبته الشديده هو تحت السيطره وان القوات
الاوكرانيه ما زالت
تتمكن من ايصال الدعم الذخائر وكذلك
المساعدات الطبيه لقواتها المتمركزه في
منطقه باكموت عبر الطريق الواصل ما بين
كوستانتيني المنطقه التي نتواجد فيها الان
ومنطقه رغم خطوره الوضع على هذا الطريق
بالاضافه طبعا الى الطرقات الفرعيه التي
هي المصدر او المكان الاساسي الذي ينطلق
منه تنطلق منه القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
منطقه بخمت لاستكمال القتال هناك هذا كله
ياتي في ظل ايضا قصف تقوم به القوات
الروسيه بصواريخ بعيده المدى وصواريخ
مضاده للطائرات والصواريخ كان اخر هذا هذه
الضربات الصاروخيه في منطقه كما تروسك
خلال الليله الماضيه